Revisor: Gastón Falanga
Salgo de TED...
y quiero cambiar.
Tengo data nueva que voy a aprovechar.
Hoy llego a mi casa y aprendo a programar.
El planeta anda mal,
calentamiento global.
Tal vez regale el auto y empiece a caminar.
No está tan mal, ya lo empiezo a disfrutar.
Y quedó atrás el tiempo que pasé discriminando...
contaminando...
anestesiado por la red social.
Pero cuidado,
mucho cuidado,
con el lado oscuro de la humanidad.
Si ese legado...
es mal usado...
por lo que entendí,
nos puede perjudicar.
Tuve una visión,
el mundo cambió:
un robot gobierna el mundo
y una piba lo creó.
La piba es de la China
y específica fue la visión.
(Risas)
Y quiero cambiar.
Salgo de TED...
No voy a ser...
No voy a ponerle nombre a lo nuevo que seré.
Y sea lo que sea lo voy a postear en una red.
(Risas)
Y nunca había pensado en lo importante
que eran mis genes.
Y mi saliva que fue escupida,
se desperdició.
Pero cuidado,
mucho cuidado,
con el lado oscuro de la humanidad.
Si ese legado...
es mal usado...
por lo que entendí,
nos puede perjudicar.
Y recuerda que los viejos
son más de lo que creemos.
Los estereotipos te hacen ver todo mal.
Y nunca dudes de los griegos,
que no es poco lo que hicieron.
Cruzate con otros, te puede iluminar.
Salgo de TED...
y me hago un haiku.
después duermo un rato.
Salgo de TED...
Lo que hoy me cierra...
es ahorrar en tierra.
Salgo de TED...
(Aplausos)
Gracias.